les situations de négociation sont de
plus en plus tendues et qu'il y a de
plus en plus de dérives donc nous sommes
obligés en tant que législateur de
légiférer nous préférerions que les
relations commerciales se passent sans
nous mais malheureusement ce n'est pas
le cas notre objectif est toujours bien
sûr de préserver la rémunération des
agriculteurs elle est de préserver les
capacités d'investissement aussi des
industries de transformation et
d'ailleurs qu'elle soit alimentaire ou
non alimentaires c'est une des
nouveautés de cette épisode égalime et
c'est véritablement que chaque la
répartition de la valeur se fasse
partout sur la chaîne de valeur
[Musique]
les principaux dysfonctionnements que
nous avons remarqué c'est d'abord un
détournement de la loi au profit des
grandes centrales européennes qui
n'étaient pas soumises à notre
législation française donc il y a une
partie de ce texte de loi qui règle dans
l'article 1 c'est ce problème de
détournement de la loi au profit des
grandes centrales européennes deuxième
élément la rémunération des agriculteurs
n'était couverte que pour les achats du
produit agricoles lorsqu'il s'agissait
de marques nationales nous avons intégré
ici au Sénat les marques distributeurs
dans cette logique de préservation des
matières premières agricoles c'est très
indépendant très important surtout
pendant cette période de d'inflation
puisque en réalité parfois sur certains
marchés c'est jusqu'à 50% des achats des
consommateurs qui sont faits sous marque
distributeur nous avons intégré les
produits non alimentaires à la
régulation des promotions alors ça ne
plaît pas au distributeur il y a aussi
des accrochages du côté de Bercy mais en
réalité c'est là pour protéger aussi
l'industrie de notre pays c'est
industrie qu'elle soit détenue par des
PME
de petites tailles ou par des grands
groupes qui disposent d'outils
industriels en France nous devons aussi
éviter le fait de perdre des marges dans
ces entreprises là et de pérenniser
l'emploi dans nos territoires c'est
évidemment très important pour nous
viennent d'autres dispositifs notamment
sur des pénalités logistiques qui
devenaient exorbitantes
[Musique]